now a contraceptive jab for men has
proved to be 96% effective in a trial
involving 350 men but researchers say
more work is needed to address the side
effects of the treatment which included
depression muscle pain and acne I'm
joined from our central London studio by
senior consultant gynecologist professor
Keaton Argand and author Peter Lloyd
he's written the book stand by your
manhood a game changer for modern men
peter lloyd to you first as this a game
changer it absolutely is the mail pail
is going to be as political as it will
be pharmaceutical for a long time men
have been on the back foot when it came
to contraceptive control and this is
gonna finally loving the plate level the
playing fields we're going to see men
being able to decide when they become
fathers rather than women deciding no
matter for them flowing over g oh
welcome it completely what about the
side effects so how much do you think
those will put men off having this
contraceptive injection because there
was some twenty men who pulled out of
the trial because they considered the
side effects to be so bad
Peter Lloyd well I think that you know
there are side effects to every medicine
so that's understandable but you know
these things are going to be in
development for a long time and
obviously those side effects are going
to be minimized and the risk is going to
be much smaller than the advantage which
is you know men have justice what's
riding on pregnancy in the long term as
women do but not nearly as much control
so this is absolutely important I
welcome it it's great yeah professor
Keaton Arkin let's bring you in on this
as Peter Lorre say men have just as much
responsibility over her pregnancy and in
the long term but in the short term it's
the women who get pregnant isn't it so
is it woman's responsibility no I don't
agree at all I contraception is a shared
responsibility and I think it's about
time and took responsibility for that
and women have been taking the pill for
decades and the side effects that risks
that go with it visiting the GP getting
repeat prescriptions
it's our I welcome this this is a very
significant and welcome development do
you think women will be willing to hand
over this responsibility and
men to be having the contraceptive
injection or perhaps be taking the male
contraceptive pill effectively yes I
think so look we need further studies as
you mentioned earlier to minimize side
effects and make sure that it is safe
and effective so I hope for the studies
will continue and it's an injection and
it's great that a long-term hormonal
injection studies have been done and I
think women will and I think women would
absolutely welcome men taking
responsibility and I think it's really
good news yeah I mean I want a pizza
Lloyd what your thoughts are on the
effectiveness of this 96% so there's
still a four percent failure rate is
that good enough for you you know I I
think it is I think 96 percent is pretty
good going at this stage in the game and
chances are that those probability
starts will increase even even more over
the next coming years but you know going
back to the last point it's funny how we
always have this debate of would women
trust men to take the contraceptive pill
I think it's ironic because that's
exactly what men have been forced to do
with women who say they're on the pill
yeah we've had a lot of responses on on
Twitter to this I want to bring some of
those here now here's dr. Mona man story
with her thoughts as a GP I welcome the
news that there could be a new male
concept available I think it's a great
idea and could be very very useful for
us in clinical practice however I would
hasten to add that so far the side
effect profile of this product has not
been very good so they might put people
off using it or prescribing it and I'd
like to see some long-term safety data
so I think we're a little way off but
something to look forward to so that
everybody can take responsibility yeah
let's have a listen to Chris Hawkins he
also sent us hair stores regarding this
issue of the male birth control pill
well it takes two to tango but both
parties I feel a equal responsible but I
would discuss it first professor it gets
an Argand I mean I think our last
contributor there into
you saying it takes two to tango it's
about time that men took responsibility
for this but I want to pick up on a
point that dr. Mona Mansoori
made about the side effects of this
there is still a long way to go isn't
there well I think the studies are going
in the right direction the side effects
so far have been I think mild to
moderate mood disorders and acne and all
that and remember 75% of men who
participated in participated in the
study we're willing to continue so it
shows that it isn't that bad in all
studies go through these phases where
you minimize side effects and come up
with dosages that are effective and
minimizing side effects and I think
we'll get there we should really welcome
this and we should not really debate
about whether women will trust or not I
think it is an issue about equality and
taking responsibility for contraception
and creating families and you know World
Health Organization has a huge
responsibility about preventive
preventing unplanned pregnancies and
birth control and it's much needed we
have needed this for a very long time
and I much welcome this yeah it's a lot
to come in there well I was gonna say I
mean it you know we've touched on the
fact that there are some side effects
for men but the contraceptive pill for
women which has been a huge phenomenal
success and it's probably the
cornerstone of feminism in many ways
also has side effects and so what a
wonderful opportunity for women who if
they perhaps have you know DVT or weight
gain or loss of libido which can
Symphony be accompanied with the female
pill if they now have an opportunity to
say to their partner well look I'm
suffering these side effects why don't
you try the male pill and perhaps you'll
fare better and then we both win I mean
what could be better than a world where
all children are planned by both parents
all the time that sounds like a pretty
good future to me yeah I wonder if it
sounds like an idealistic vision though
a Peter Lloyd I know you know many of
your female friends will be you know
welcoming what you're saying that you
know women have put up with the side
effects for years and now it's men's
turn but how many of you
male friends do you think are prepared
to deal with potential weight game with
mood issues for example acne those kinds
of things for this
well many men take drugs such as rocky
saying which also have implications with
side effects you know which also include
weight gain and mood and depression but
you know it's about calculating your
risk at the beginning and realizing you
know it is the benefit going to be
greater than the risk and I think in
this situation when you're talking about
creating a human life which is going to
change you you know in the course of
your life in your line egde and your
finances for the rest of your life is
crucially important so look if it was my
choice and I had to choose between
putting on two stone and not having a
child I didn't want it great I'd take it
in a heartbeat and all men should do the
same and professor now going I wonder
what you make of the long-term
implications of this how much do we know
about men recovering at their fertility
once they come off these contraceptive
injections well so far this study has
shown good results and I think around
eight men in this study had the where
the sperm comes hadn't come back to
normal but that's a small number at this
stage and he does require long term
studies as well as larger numbers you
know more centers in more with larger
numbers and I'm convinced if these
studies are continued not only that we
would have seen achieve the efficacy but
also we will achieve the levels of
hormones to be given in order to
minimize side effect so it's so far it
seems to be a success story
yeah but of course it goes without
saying it doesn't protects against STDs
does it well it doesn't protect against
STDs but I think the campaign about STDs
will continue and I think we really need
to look at the long-term contraception
goals shared responsibility and a
worldwide responsibility when it comes
to birth control and this particular
development is aimed at achieving that
and we should continue a campaign about
preventing sexually transmitted diseases
and I think they should go hand-in-hand
let's all
forget the female contraceptive pill has
been no less of a success even though
that itself doesn't protect against STDs
so it's a bit of a red herring argument
really we know it's important to protect
against STDs of course it is but human
life creating human life especially if
it's not planned and it's not wanted
that's the bigger benefit if you can
avoid that okay peace of life s ogitta
noggin thank you both very much